All of these but one are correct. We saw in the problem we did for Grant that we
have to change both sides of an equation in the same way to make sure that we
maintain equality. So this last choice down here is correct. The answer we ended
up with also was a way of expressing an unknown quantity in terms of other
information that we had, which is this third choice. When we found that c equals
6.5, we could plug that number back into our original equation to make it a true
equation. So, this first answer works as well. We could not, however, change one
side of our equation. We could not, however, change one side of our equation in
a different way than the other side. And we also didn't have in mind, in
advance, what number we wanted the variable to equal. So, this answer right
here, the second one, is not something that we want to select.